piège se tortiller sauter courir quelqu'un nous avons
peur je sais que je vais être là dans ta
tête en train de te parler le temps choc se
tortiller viens sur le camion ralentit bien
quelqu'un de bien
Jack écoute moi c'est notre chance
merci de nous laisser  faites cette
interview, nous sommes reconnaissants d'entendre votre
histoire merci à tous ceux qui sont et
Thurgood pensées et leurs prières pendant
cinq ans vous avez rendu la vie dans cette petite
pièce cette prison aussi nourrissante et normale
que vous le pouviez et vous savez que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui  ce que nous allons faire un
gâteau d'anniversaire tu as choisi de dire à Jack
cette pièce était le monde entier qu'il n'y
avait rien d'autre une plante de deuil
bonjour évier je voulais qu'il se sente en
sécurité que c'était un endroit idéal pour
lui n'as-tu jamais  pense que tu serais
libre
j'espère que Jack merci d'avoir sauvé son look
fille
Carine une autre planète la même juste un
endroit différent oh comme c'est gentil
ceux qui tapent dans le monde 37 heures alors que
nous tirons les fenêtres isil des centaines de voitures
et d'oiseaux dans grand-mère et grand-père
vous  ah quelqu'un ici aime te rencontrer saint
ami nous non tu ne nous trouveras jamais
tout le monde demande oh peux tu jamais aucune
idée de ce qui se passe dans ma tête bien essaie
moi et chaque fois que tu me regardes c'est
tout ce que tu vois quand je te regarde  Joie
je verrai ma fille
tu vas l'adorer tout le monde
Oh